hi everyone there are plenty of seats
down here if anyone wants to move
downstairs okay so welcome to today's
seminar as you well know biomedical
research has flourished in this country
due in a very large part to the
visionary establishment of both
intramural and extramural research
programs supported by the national
institutes of health every day now we
see and hear about newly acquired
information from labs large and small
working on understanding all aspects of
biology much of which has direct impact
on human health and well-being and often
from very unexpected in very unexpected
ways we are now in a period in which the
biomedical research Enterprise is being
squeezed by at least two forces one
caused by our own success in attracting
bright people to research careers
swelling the size of our enterprise and
one caused by recessionary and political
forces that have resulted in reducing
overall research dollars available to
support these talented people as a
research scientist myself and now Dean
of the graduate school I'm very happy to
have with us here today Jon Lorsch to
talk about his ideas for stabilizing the
biomedical research Enterprise jon is
director of the National Institute of
General Medical Sciences which provides
a major portion of funding for basic
research and biological mechanisms in a
wide variety of model systems and also
provides the majority of funding for the
training of young scientists thus his
ideas and NIGMS policies have a huge
ripple effect on all of science John
moved to NIH to almost two years ago
from Johns Hopkins University where he
was a professor in the biophysics and
biophysical chemistry department his
research interests are in structural
analysis of the eukaryotic translation
machinery he moved his research group to
NIH meaning he's still very much one of
us facing the challenges of maintaining
a research program
while also examining ways the NIH can
help us I'll do this better so please
join me in welcoming John here today
thank you thank you been so my life here
you can hear me good thank you very much
for the invitation to speak here it's
been a great visit so far I got to talk
about science yesterday and I'm going to
talk about science policy I want to talk
about some of the challenges that land
alluded to and some ideas we have for
how we can meet those challenges so one
of the things I hope to convince you of
during the course of the talk is that
the future is actually not so grim and
that we really can if we work together
improve the efficiency and the
sustainability of the enterprise and
that the future actually is potentially
quite bright but again it's going to
take all of us working together to get
there since I'm at a medical school I'll
tell you that whatever rules you have I
have a hundred times more so you don't
have to worry so I know many of you are
familiar with NIGMS but let me just give
you a brief overview for those of you
who art the institute has two
overarching missions the first is to
promote fundamental research on living
systems in order to lay the foundation
for advances in disease diagnosis
treatment and prevention and the second
mission which is actually related
closely the first is to enable the
development of the best trained most
innovative and productive biomedical
research workforce possible and I will
just highlight this phrase here lay the
foundation because that really is the
fundamental mission that ni GMS is
trying to achieve so the research we
support the training we promote are
really laying the foundations on which
the other 26 nih institutes and centers
promote their missions there are
missions that are focused on specific
diseases or specific organ systems okay
now they say you don't know an NIH
Institute until you know its budget so
let me tell
a little bit about our budget the fiscal
year 2015 budget was almost two point
three seven billion dollars it's a
little bit less than it was pre
sequester but I think you'll all agree
it's still a very significant amount of
money the way we disperse this money is
that about ninety percent of it goes to
support extramural research so that's
research conducted outside the walls of
NIH at medical schools universities
other research institutes across the
country close to nine or ten percent of
the budget goes to our training
workforce development diversity building
mission that's a little bit fuzzy
because some of the things going on out
here in the blue area in research are
awesome related to workforce development
and training but what you can see from
this is that we are on almost completely
outward-facing Institute we have only
one very small intramural program which
is a single postdoctoral research
training program that funds postdoctoral
fellows to work at NIH institutes and at
the FDA about 20 of them a year so again
we are almost completely outward-facing
focusing on supporting research
throughout the United States now one
thing I always like to say a very
important point is that that two point
three seven billion dollars i mentioned
to you is not monopoly money ok and this
is something I take extremely seriously
that two point three seven billion
dollar budget we have is hard-earned
taxpayer money and so it's absolutely
incumbent on up on us to make sure that
that taxpayer money is being invested in
the best possible way so really our job
is to ensure that the taxpayers funds
are invested in fundamental biomedical
research in the most efficient and
effective ways possible that is to get
them the best returns the most and the
best science possible for their money
okay and that's something I think we all
need to keep in our minds at all times
whether you are the person deciding how
the money is invested or you are the
recipients of that money
so this year just a few months ago we
released our five-year strategic plan
and I encourage you to go to our website
you don't have to write this whole thing
down you can just go to the NIGMS
website and find this but it lays out
the general themes goals and strategies
to accomplish these objectives and goals
that the Institute intends to pursue
over the next five years one of the
really key areas that we are focusing on
as part of the strategic plan is
reinvigorating our commitment to
investigator-initiated research and so
you might say well why does NIGMS which
has historically been the home of
fundamental investigator-initiated
research need to focus on reinvigorating
its commitment to that and the the data
behind that decision are shown here this
shows two different but related things
the blue bars which are this axis over
here show the funds that NIGMS had
committed to what you might call
programmatic research or specific
investments in certain scientific areas
in which the funds were set aside for
those scientific areas to be less
favorable you might call it top-down
research in which NIH in consultation
with members of the research community
decide to put aside a certain amount of
the budget and targeted at a specific
scientific area and you can see that in
the early 1990s over here nigms had
almost no money invested in this kind of
programmatic top-down research but
between 1998 or thereabouts-- and 2003
or so and actually for some years after
that over here you can see that that
amount of money grew dramatically in
1998 to 2003 corresponds to the doubling
of the NIH budget and so during that
time other uses for the amount of money
that was continually coming into the
system each year were found and it was
put into these kinds of targeted
scientific initiatives now the red line
which is the other axis the right-hand
axis over here
represents the percent of NIGMS research
portfolio that was dedicated to
investigator-initiated research sort of
the reciprocal of these blue bars and
again you can see that in the early
1990s 99% of the Institute's portfolio
was investigator-initiated research but
during the budget doubling and in the
years following it that percentage fell
to the level it was in 2013 when i
arrived at NIGMS of only eighty percent
so we went from one percent targeted
research in our portfolio to twenty
percent in the course of about a decade
or so now we've concluded that since the
budget doubling has been over for 15
years it really is necessary at this
point for us to shift this balance to
bring this red line back up which is
going to mean bringing these blue bars
down and that's something we've been
focusing on both in the short term by
making strategic decisions about how we
are distributing our portfolio and what
programs we are investing in and keeping
running and also in the long term as we
think about how best to support science
and the overall enterprise that that we
fund now another way you can see the
need for us to refocus our efforts on
investigator-initiated research is to
look at what we call the success rate
for grants ok so this plot shows three
related things on this axis over here
are the number of research project grant
your applications in the blue line that
were submitted to NIGMS research project
grants our grants to generally
individual or small teams investigators
and what we're looking at here is
investigator-initiated grants the lion's
share of RPGs are made up of ro ones
which are the really bread and butter of
the biomedical research enterprise so
again the blue lines are the
applications we received versus fiscal
year the red lines are the number of
awards we made so the number of grants
we actually funded and then the green
line is what we call the success rate
this is the number of grants we funded
divided by the total of
applications each year and so what you
can see is that this green line started
out at the end of the budget doubling
nearly forty percent so nearly forty
percent of the applications we received
in a year were being funded at the end
of the budget doubling this began to
fall as the doubling receded to the
point where in 2013 I arrived at a GMS
it had fallen to a historic low of
twenty percent ok so it had almost been
cut in half over that period of ten
years we predicted based on modeling and
expected levels of grants or
applications that if we didn't make any
changes to our portfolio it was going to
stay stagnant at twenty percent and so a
variety of changes in our portfolio we
made for instance we reduce the number
of funding opportunity announcements
targeted specific scientific areas that
we had out we reduced the budgets of the
large centers that we supported longer
term we've made decision to close some
large initiatives that have been ongoing
since the beginning of the budget
doubling and we did see some improvement
this year so rather than being stagnant
of twenty percent the success rate
actually rose the twenty-five percent
now so that's positive news to be sure
but just two points about it one is it's
critical as we move forward and continue
to think about how we distribute our
funds and manage our portfolio that we
keep this success rate at least this
high if not increase it further rather
than let this be a spike of a single
year followed by a return to these poor
success rates the other point i'll make
those I don't view this twenty five
percent success rate is good enough yet
I think we really need to continue to
work on this to make sure that all the
outstanding or as many outstanding
investigators as we can who are
struggling to get support are able to
conduct and continue their research so
those are two things that will be
working on over the coming years now
that's just an introduction to some of
the directions we're heading globally
and again I encourage you to go look at
our strategic plan to find out more
details and more of our thinking about
other areas but people frequently asked
me what I do all day long and what I do
all day long in addition to going to a
lot of meetings is to think about very
hard problems and that's one of the
appeals for me for this job and one of
the reasons I took it i get to think
about very important very hard problems
that if we could solve would really make
a big positive impact on the research
enterprise and i won't go through all
these here but these show some of the
hard problems that i spend my time
thinking about their things like the
distribution of funding among
investigators the academic business
model how the scientific reward system
feeds into both productive and
unproductive parts of the enterprise and
issues related to the workforce and
training and how many people we can
support and are we adequately training
them for example but what I realized as
I thought about all these very hard
problems is there was really one central
problem that fed into all these other
hard problems in different ways okay
that influenced each of these hard
problems in one way or another and I
determined at least I thought that if we
couldn't solve that central hard problem
we were going to have a very hard time
making a significant impact on these
other heart problems and that central
hard problem in my view is how we
support fundamental research so as many
of you know the way we fund some
fundamental research right now largely
through the ro1 mechanism that I
mentioned a minute ago is a project
based funding model so we asked
researchers to decide what they're doing
in their lab and to break that up their
projects the research in their lab up
into specific projects and then predict
four or five years in advance exactly
what they're going to be working on
right down to hear the experiments i'm
going to do over the next four or five
years here are even the controls i think
i'm going to do and we let them break
their research up as much as they are
native enough to do and apply for as
many grants as they can write in terms
of those projects they've now broken
their research up into now many people
myself included think that this project
based funding system creates a number of
inefficiencies in the enterprise I'm not
going to enumerate them all but let me
just tell you to in my view the first is
that this is not how science actually
works right at least not the best
science right if you can tell me exactly
the experiments you're going to do over
the next four years I think they're
probably not worth doing okay the best
science is when you're following your
nose and you find something interesting
and you go off in that direction and and
Enrique gets a new idea when he's in the
shower right and it goes into lab and
makes us students change directions
right that's when the big exciting stuff
tends to happen okay and here we're
constraining this we're putting a
constraint on how science actually works
and we're trying to fit a round peg into
a square hole or vice versa is that's
one problem doesn't reflect how the best
science actually happens the other
problem is related to this this hard
problem distribution of funding as I
mentioned because we let people break
their research up into as many different
individual projects or grants as they
are creative enough to subdivide and get
as many of those as they are able to
convince study sections to give them
we've created a very skewed distribution
of funding in the biomedical research
enterprise and let me just show you that
for a second okay so here what we've
done is we've taken nigms grantees so
these are people that have at least one
NIGMS grant and we've counted the amount
of NIH total direct costs each one has
okay so this isn't counting hhmi or
anything else this is just NIH funding
and then we've put them in bins based on
the top part of that funding district so
this is the people who have up to 185
thousand direct costs up to 210 up to
320 etc okay and so you can see what the
distribution of our portfolio looks like
now the red line is the average number
of NIH grants that each one of
the investigators in each of those bins
has so it goes from one all the way up
to about four and a half okay now if you
analyze this in a slightly different way
what you find is that five percent of
our grantees have twenty-five percent of
the NIH funds that our grantees have and
twenty percent of them have a half okay
well maybe that's weird nigms thing but
if you look at the entire NIH portfolio
it's exactly the same distribution okay
now that's a pretty skewed long tailed
distribution there was an article in The
New York Times about a year ago talking
about Medicare or reimbursement to
doctors and physicians and how skewed it
was and how big a problem this was going
to become and it was exactly the same
skew five percent get a quarter twenty
percent get a half so if it's a problem
there I think I can make an argument
that it's not the most efficient thing
here now you say well okay how much
money if you could recover some of that
money how much would it really put back
in the system to help fund new
investigators to help keep really
productive excellent labs open and if
you just count the NIGMS direct costs
that the people who have over half a
million dollars a year in NIH costs have
it's almost four hundred million dollars
okay so even if i could only recover ten
percent of that money that would still
be 40 million dollars i could put back
into our funding system okay so i'm not
talking about insignificant tweaking the
edges there really is significant
improvements in the distribution that
could be done to help young
investigators to help outstanding labs
that are trying to get by on you know
single grant with five people in the lab
now counter-argument to this always says
well the people that have that great
amount of money the five percent they
have their the five percent because
they're the best scientist and they're
getting us the most for the money
they're making the big discoveries
they're publishing all the papers turns
out and try to be as data-driven as i
can in thinking about these things it
turns out that we have an increasing
body of evidence that
indicates that that is not true at least
not on average okay so this was an
analysis that was done in 2010 led by
Jeremy Berg when he was director of
NIGMS and what it shows is in red the
number of publications that arose from a
grant during the grant period as a
function of total annual NIH direct
costs of the grantees it's the average
or the average impact factor of the
journal in which that group published
papers okay that's you know both of
these are flawed metrics someone could
publish one paper that's much more
important than someone else's ten papers
but we're talking about averages here so
some of those things get buffered out
okay what you see and these are the
interquartile ranges these bars so you
can see there's a big range okay that's
true but what's really striking to me
about this curve is okay the beginning
part of the curve it goes up very
rapidly as you'd expect if you have no
money you're not doing much but when you
get to somewhere and that's a three
hundred thousand dollar range of direct
costs a year when you go above that you
start to see although it does increase
productivity in terms of papers or in
terms of the impact factor the curve the
slope is very shallow which is
diminishing returns okay you are not
getting a unit increase in productivity
or impact for unit increase in funding
levels and what was one thing striking
in these data was that once you got
above about 700 750 thousand dollars the
actual net amount of productivity that
was coming out of these things was
actually decreasing okay now there are
all kinds of reasons for this to me it
comes down to bandwidth okay if you're
focusing on you know the stuff in your
lab that's the core and what you're most
excited about you're going to be be able
to put more bandwidth into that you're
gonna be able to mentor the students are
going to come up with more ideas as you
subdivide that more and more right
that's going to get come down the amount
of ideas you have the amount of time you
have to put into it the amount of time
you have to mentor is going to decrease
and of course the amount of time you
have to spend
trying to keep this enterprise funded is
going to go up and up which is time
taken away from doing the actual
research and mentoring and training ok
now I do a simple back-of-the-envelope
calculation to make this point a little
more clearly my job fundamentally is to
act as an investor of the taxpayers
money ok I'm trying to optimize the
returns in terms of as I said great
science the amount in the quality that
we get for the amount of money that
Congress decides to give us whatever
that is and you can do using these
averages a calculation we say okay well
I have a choice and I'm frequently faced
with this choice that's in any given
council round one grant application k
man it's from an established p i got a
great score l say it got a 5 percentile
it's to get the established p I who now
has currently has two are ones and
getting 400,000 direct costs a third ro1
so they're going to go from four hundred
thousand dollars here to six hundred
thousand dollars here if we give them
the grand that's actually going to buy
the taxpayer on average one more paper a
year okay now that's an average okay
there are people who can really do
better and beat the curve but note that
although there are people who can do
better and beat the curve there are by
the same token people who do worse who
aren't getting funded because that's
what I'm showing you here okay so that's
one the other is a new investigator okay
she's coming in for her first grant
it'll be the only funding she had she's
going to go from essentially zero to say
200,000 that's going to buy the
taxpayers on average five papers so the
difference is for papers again okay I'm
talking averages there's all kinds of
caveats here but from an investment
point of view which one's the better bit
okay so that's kind of thinking that I'm
trying to do another way of putting this
is what should our funding metric be
what should our measure of how we are
funding science be currently it's the
number of grants we give okay we say how
many grants begin what's the success
rate of grant applications that
denominator being nap
patient's the numerator being the number
of funded grants but another way another
way to think about this what we should
be focusing on is how many investigators
are we supporting ok now that when I
first say it often sounds trivial well
ok you're shifting from grants to
investigators but it really is not
trivial it's a different focus right
we're now trying to say what we the NIH
wants to do is to maximize productivity
and impact by focusing on how many
investigators were going to support at
sustainable levels ok rather than just
throwing it open and saying here's
grants go get them and seeing how many
people can you know scurry up four or
five grants okay it really is a
different focus and it's something that
we not just a tent at GMS but nih-wide
are talking about should this be more of
the thing that we're focusing on ok so
this kind of thinking has led us to
start an experiment which I want to tell
you about now it's called the maximizing
investigators research award I'll tell
you the details in a second the overall
idea is to switch from a model in which
we are funding projects and letting
people get as many grants as that can
for their projects to one in which we
are supporting research programs ok
which would be a single grant to support
the work in your lab much more flexible
as I'll tell you hopefully more
sustainable more secure but once you
have that grant that's your NIGMS
research funding and we're not going to
give you any more at least for that five
year period ok now what do we think the
advantages of this mechanism are before
I go through the details and we think
there are a number of potential
advantages to this the first is to
increase the stability of funding I'll
show you how we're going to do that but
we think that if we can increase the
stability of funding we will actually
get better science from people because
they will be willing to take on more
ambitious projects and approach them
more creatively flipping this around I
think many people agree that the
instability of funding the constant
worry that you're going to fall off the
funding cliff and be unfunded or have to
lay out
half your lab makes people conservative
makes people conservative and the
science they propose and they attempt
and it makes study sections conservative
in the science they fund so that's one
man the second is to increase
flexibility for investigators to let
them follow their noses like I said and
change directions as new opportunities
arise as Anna Rica has new ideas in the
shower right his labs cringing right now
but you know we want to give them that
flexibility the classic example I like
to give for why this is important is
RNAi okay RNAi came from a failed
control experiment right they did a
control experiment they saw they were
doing anti sense RNA they put in the
sense strand and it worked just as well
as the anti-sense Durant right now could
have ignored this said well that's weird
something strange is going on luckily
Andy fire had the courage in fact the
resources because he was at the carnegie
institute and the freedom to follow this
because he wasn't tied to specific games
and he did and hence RNAi was discovered
that we have this amazing new
understanding of a central biological
process and there's amazing new
technology what I worry about won't
don't know the answer but I want to
worry about is how many amazing
discoveries have not been made because
when the graduate student of the postdoc
went to the PI and said look at this
weird result this weird control the P I
said that is kind of weird but I've got
to renew this grant at 18 months so you
got to get back to the specific aims
because otherwise we're doomed right I
don't know the answer but I suspect more
than a few great discoveries remain
unmade because of that as I mentioned we
also want to improve the distribution of
funding ok now we recognize there still
needs to be arranged that some people
really can efficiently use more money
than the average but we need to get to a
situation that is optimized relative to
where we are that distribution I showed
you and one of the reasons is because we
have no idea where the next big
discovery is going to come from just
like that rnai case and we know from
looking back at the history of science
that discoveries come from all kinds of
strange and
spected places many of them are made at
Yale but many of them are not made at
Yale right they can be made all over by
all kinds of people studying all kinds
of strange unusual organisms for example
again going to my investor analogy if
you're investing in the stock market and
you only invest in the blue-chip stocks
you're going to get in general a poor
return than if you have a distributed
investment portfolio because that
maximizes the chances of the big
occasional payoff and also mitigates
your risks okay so that's I think
another core concept here we also want
to reduce the time investigators spend
writing grant applications right again
if you're trying to run a lab where you
are trying to keep yourself funded
either because you want three or four
lat grants or just to keep that one and
you're writing multiple grants every
year that's time that you're not
spending thinking about the day-to-day
signs and what's going to be really be
done next as opposed to try to predict
in four years what you'll be doing as
time you're not mentoring or teaching
your students okay so I think we really
again could improve the quality and
maybe the amount of science that came
out of each unit lab if we would free
peoples time up by reducing the amount
of grant writing they had to do related
to that we'd like to reduce the amount
of grants that have to be reviewed okay
people say to me wherever I go peer
review is broken right you know peer
review is the problem you gotta fix peer
review tweak it here do this you know
change 12 pages is enough 25 peer review
is not broken okay peer review is just
being asked to do something it cannot do
right what peer review can do well is it
can put things into bins it can say
here's promising stuff you know this
looks really promising here's maybe you
know maybe promising not quite as much
here's the next year maybe there's a
fourth tier all right but the notion
that we can rank grants that I can say
this grant on drosophila I development
is ranked you know is actually more
predictively more likely to give a great
result than this grant on CL again
and ovary development you know which got
a fifth percentile instead of a first
percentile not only does it just
intellectually not really work we now
have an increasing body of data that
it's not true okay so the best thing we
could do for peer review the way we
could fix quote uncle peer review is to
reduce the number of applications
they're being asked to deal with to let
them do what they can do which again is
you know make broader distinctions and
to increase the success rate right if
the success rate is let's just say fifty
percent that's a whole different world
than if the success rate is fifteen
percent all right okay so those are some
of the things we hope to achieve so the
program again is mira maximizing
investigators research awards it's an
experiment it's hopefully experiment
that's going to be expanding my goal
would be to expand it rapidly if it
begins to work but let me tell you about
what it's going to look like it's going
to be a single research grant / pi/4
NIGMS it's going to use a new mechanism
called an hour 35 they will because it's
going to be a single grant on average be
bigger than what we currently give right
we want to give you enough money so you
can do your research we want to get you
in the sweet spot okay so whatever
that's going to be based on our budget
etc and it's going to be a year longer
than our current ro1 so currently four
years is the average are 100 GMS easing
me five years there's going to be a
range of direct costs as i said some
people are going to be able to convince
the study sections that they really can
use more than the median amount of money
efficiently and get you know unit
increase in productivity at least but
the range is going to be from something
small to 750 thousand dollars that's
going to be the cap okay not to give us
based on the data I showed you is
basically what we think that's the most
money that NIGMS should be investing in
anyone very few in terms of research
very few people will get that much money
but that is going to be the limit
they're not going to be tie
the specific aims in fact the grants
don't have specific games instead the
review is going to be based really on
two things one is retrospective what did
you do in the last period of time
whether that be five years or ten years
okay that's actually turns out to be one
of the better predictors for these
established investigators of what
they're going to do in the future the
other will be just lay out broadly what
this area is you're working on what you
think the key questions are and what you
think the strategies are for approaching
them okay you got to have something some
vision that we assess but you're not
going to be tied to that so if your
postdoc finds something unusual in a
control experiment in year one point
five and that sends you off in a new
direction that is perfectly fine in fact
you're not even gonna tell the study
section when you come in for renewal and
i should say these grants will be
renewable what the specific aims were
originally you're just going to tell
them what you did and again over all the
questions that a program strategies you
think you're going to follow in terms of
stability i mentioned that's a key
aspect of this we would like to improve
the stability of the system so people
aren't constantly popping in and out of
being funded not being funded are coming
from two grants to 15 years versus four
is one piece of that that's you know
maybe a minor thing but an extra year I
think from my point of view is is a
positive but maybe more importantly
we're going to be switching from the
current binary outcome of peer review or
you're either funded or you're not right
to one that's analog so that's sounds
sort of retro we're going from digital
to analog the idea though is that we'll
be able to modulate funding levels based
on peer review rather than necessarily
terminating your grant so say you come
in to peer review now and the study
section says oh you did it was great
work it's pretty interesting stuff that
you're talking about doing but you're
not the top one or two grants in my pile
so you gotta you know 37 or something
like that it's still a great score
chances are now you're not getting
funded at all in this new model
we're going to do is have the ability to
say okay look they're saying you weren't
operating at the four hundred thousand
dollar direct cost level that you were
at but rather than just terminate your
program we're just going to ramp you
down to something else okay so you keep
going you have to downsize a little bit
but you're not finished you can keep
your program moving okay I think that
really will allow us a lot more
flexibility and ability to keep the
system stabilized and currently the
on/off system that we have now I was
determined when we were writing coming
up with this idea that I wanted to let
new and early stage investigators into
this program from the start there's a
lot of debate should we make them do our
ones first and then let them come in and
one of the good things about my job is I
could occasionally make an executive
decision so this is what I made we are
going to let new and early stage
investigators straight into this system
but the pushback is always well you're
basing this on track record in large
part that's going to disadvantaged young
investigators and of course it would if
we were comparing them to the
established investigators in the same
panel so what we're doing is we're going
to have distinct separate panels for the
established investigators and the young
investigators and different criteria
modified criteria for the investigators
okay so in some ways that's even better
than the current system because they're
not going to be in the same study
section and they're going to be judged
in separate hopefully improved ways now
sometimes it's useful to say to define
something by what it's not so I do want
to make a couple things clear but what
nearer is not so mirror is not targeted
specifically at high-risk high-reward
research so this isn't the Pioneer
program pioneer award for one thing this
is renewable this is hopefully going to
be a sustainable system we do hope that
the benefits i told you about will
empower people to do more ambitious and
more creative research but we're not
targeting it just at you know you've got
some crazy high-risk idea we want this
to be for all the great science that
traditionally funds and by the same
token it's not targeted specifically at
a perceived highly League group ok so we
are not creating hhmi here although
we're using some of the I think you know
beneficial aspects of that kind of
person or program based funding again if
this pilot experiment works the idea
would be to expand it to be able to fund
the entire portfolio of NIGMS
investigators okay all of whom are
excellent least in my view now what's
the initial implementation plan going to
be and here's where the rub starts
because we can't as much as I would love
to just say everyone come in right now
you know the pool is open and the reason
is because a we don't know if that's
going to work so you know if there's
some problem we don't want to throw
everything into one system and then find
out there's a problem most importantly
we have to pilot the peer review system
because everyone agrees that this is
going to rise or fall on how peer review
works and the peer review really has to
be very different than the current ro1
peer review anyways it's got to be
orthogonal to it so we can't just let
the CSR ro1 study sections start
reviewing these right next to ro ones
because they're going to review them
like our ones and we can't have that
okay so we really have to break the mole
the peer review in many ways start a
separate system and try to make it work
for what we're trying to accomplish here
and to do that we need a moderate number
of applications so we can test these
procedures and so we've already issued
the first fo a and the first day I fo a
is for established p is and in order to
get a small enough test group we had to
put some constraints in so the
constraints are that they either have
two or more NIGMS are ones already or
one that's for over 400,000 and direct
cost so this immediately sounds like
you're creating the elite group ok but
remember that we are actually going to
be asking these people to trade some
amount of their direct costs on average
for the benefits of the system and put
that money back into the system
to you know improve the number of labs
we can support of the quality of support
we give them okay so that's trade-off
they're going to lose a little bit of
direct costs in exchange for all these
benefits extra year etc now the second
one which we are writing and is now
going through the approval process is
for new investigators who are at an
early stage of their careers as I said I
was determined to let them in and again
we're gonna have separate review panels
and criteria for them if these start to
look like they're successful it is if
people apply for it if no one goes to
Tahiti instead of doing their research
and you know continues to be productive
we are going to expand this as fast as
we can the goal would be to open it to
everyone as soon as possible but we
really want to make sure we have the
peer review process worked out as well
as we can first okay now I wanted to
since I talked about new investigators
just talk briefly about some new data we
have concerning new investigators and
early-stage investigators because that's
an area i'm very concerned about is
getting these great scientists into the
system funding system as soon as we can
to you know get their labs off the
ground and get them producing and then
keep it sustained okay because if we
lose a generation of scientists because
we're not focusing on this it's really
going to be a detriment to the country
now one of the ways NIH has tried to
support young investigators getting into
the system is by mandating that every
Institute and center is supposed to keep
the success rate for grants to new
investigators at least as good as the
success rates for new grants to
established investigators so new grants
to establish investigators and these are
anti GMS data es is our early stage
investigators young investigators and
then the red bars of the experience p is
and you can see that over the last five
years nigms has been successful in
keeping the success rate above the
success rate for new grants for
experienced p is but note that the
success rate for new grants for
experienced p is is actually not very
high
I okay and so one question I do have and
I'm wrestling with is whether this is
the right bar as I'll show in just a
second the success rate for renewing a
grant for an established p I is
dramatically higher than this okay so
we've set the bar pretty low and we're
saying it has to be at least as good as
the hardest thing you know that you can
do and I wonder if maybe we need
something a little bit better than that
but another area we've been concerned
about is the first renewal so
investigate we're already giving new
investigators early stage investigators
some break maybe it's not enough of a
break we give us on break we get them
into the system and then we've been
worried about what happens to them when
they come up for their first renewal
because anecdotally this has been said
to be really the stage at which they
rise or fall okay and it's very hard to
get that first renewal so one of my
program director Stefan Moss has been
taking a deep dive into the literature
into our data looking at this and so let
me just show you what we have here on
the left over here is the percent of
projects for all renewals of established
investigators so these are renewals of a
new grant or renewals of a grant that's
in its you know fifth renewal cycle all
four established investigators in green
are the grants that got funded or what
we call paid in red are the grants that
were submitted for renewal but not
funded and in blue are grants that never
came in for renewal all there was no
application okay in yellow this yellow
dot shows the success rate because the
success rate is just the total number of
applications on the denominator and
those that were funded in the numerator
not taking into account all the ones
that never came in at all okay and so
you can see the success rate overall for
all renewals for stablished pis is very
high okay and it actually gets higher
with each renewal cycle up to the third
renewal cycle so the first one is a
little bit harder than the second the
third is the easiest thereafter Stefan
then broke that down into renewals of
new projects by established investigator
so he took out just the first renewals
of new grants going to establish
investigators and he compared that to
renewals of new projects from new
investigators as their first renewal of
their first grant and what he found was
that overall this the renewal rate is
just the percentage of projects that get
renewed was higher for new investigators
than for established new Vista Gators
renewing a new grant so that seemed good
because that means that you know they're
getting renewed more often than a new
grant to an established investigator but
when we looked at up you know a little
more closely you realize that in fact if
you compare the red and the green bars
the success rate again the yellow dot is
actually higher for renewing new grants
for established investigators than
renewing new grants for new
investigators it's not dramatically
higher but it's a little bit higher and
so that's consistent with the lore that
it's hard to get that first or no and
that certainly concerns us and so an
area that we want to focus on is this
first renewal and how can we make sure
that you know great new investigators
are making it through this really
critical stage the first renewal but
another weird thing that you'll note in
this we'll talk about more in a second
is that this blue bar for established
investigators is much bigger than the
blue bar for new investigators so almost
40 of actually 45-percent close to fifty
percent of new projects funded for
established investigators never come in
for renewal they just walk away from
them for one reason or another and
that's something that we're interested
in though excuse me discuss more in just
a second but another thing that Stefan
did was to look at how the renewal rate
compared to the initial score of that
first application so we're looking at
new grants either for establish p eyes
or new pies ok and he looked at the
percentile score that that grant got
when it was initially funded and then
compared that or been that for the
renewal rate when it came in for renewal
okay and so on the left now are the new
investigators and on the right of the
established and if you follow the green
bar for the established you see that it
goes down as the original grants
percentile score gets worse that's what
you'd expect perhaps priori you might
think that you'd get more successful
projects from the higher scoring
applications perhaps but if you compare
the new investigators bars you'll know
that the trend is not the same in fact
the renewal rate for new investigators
who are funded with grants that got at
or above the 20th percentile and these
were generally grants that we were what
we call reaching for right they were
above where we generally would be
funding and because there were new
investigators we reached for them
there's renewal rate is actually higher
than the renewal rate of the established
investigators and even about the same as
the renewal rate of the new
investigators who scored in the 02 ninth
percentile right so this really supports
the idea that we should be as we are
doing giving some benefit to new
investigators in that first grant when
we fund them because it appears that the
ones we reach for actually are doing
quite well both relative to new
investigators who scored better and to
established investigators okay so that
does support that but again I want to
address this issue of the disparity
between the fraction of grants that
never come in for a renewal of a new
grant for established a new
investigators in that trend you can see
here quite clearly now one possibility
was that these grants that don't come in
for a renewal don't come in for a
renewal on average because they are not
success as successful as the ones that
do and what this would then be telling
us is that almost half of the new grants
we give to establish p is these are new
grants not renewals weren't very
successful in that could be because of
bandwidth you know if you're giving a
p.i their third grant you don't have as
much time to devote to it so this is you
know
thing I think we need to think about I
will say that sixty percent of the
established p is in this pool who are
getting new grants have at least one
other grant from us so Stefan broke each
of these cohorts up that I just showed
you the new investigators they
established according to whether they
did not apply for renewal so t2
application is a renewal of that new
grant they applied for one and then they
further subdivided the ones who applied
for a renewal according to those who
didn't get funded and those who did get
funded and what he's looking at here
he's looked at it in about 16 different
ways to measure productivity and impact
I'm just going to show you two but he
has again hun of 16 probably different
ways of looking at it this is looking at
the number of publications that came out
of that grant period / dollars so per
million dollars for each of these
cohorts these are box plots the black
line is the median and then the top is
the 75th percentile on the bottom of the
25th and the full range is shown here
okay and what you see is in fact
according to publications per unit
dollars the lowest cohort is the ones
that didn't come in for renewal at all
it's lower than the ones that did come
in for renewal and that's kind of what
you'd expect if this group was just not
as successful so they didn't come in for
renewal and the best overall look like
the ones that were actually funded which
is somewhat heartening ok now another
way to look at that is citations per
million dollars the citations for the
papers that came out of that grant
period again / dollars and he sees the
same trend which is that the lowest is
the ones that never came in for renewal
the highest is the ones that did come in
for renewal
ok so this supports the idea again that
the reason on average that these people
are not renewing their grants is because
the projects were not as successful and
he's looked at other measures of impact
using various Thompson Reuters thing
using some internal NIH measures we see
the same thing over and over again the
other thing that's striking is that when
you compare the new investigators impact
or productivity to the established
investigators it is always at least as
good in some cases it's better okay so
this again supports the notion that it
is a good investment to fund grants
first grants for new investigators
because they are doing at least as well
by all these different metrics if not
better than a new grant yet another
grant to established bi now the very
last thing I want to say before it took
some questions is I mentioned that the
other mission of NIGMS is training and
there are lots of important things going
on in the training arena and I didn't
want to short change that by not saying
anything about it so let me just very
quickly tell you some of the important
areas we're thinking about in terms of
workforce development and training the
first is developing the optimal
workforce and one of the key areas we're
focusing on there is building diversity
and I mean diversity very broadly going
back to my investor analogy from
scientific questions two approaches two
regions and to the backgrounds of the
people doing the research and the reason
that's so important is because diversity
improves performance has been shown in
many different arenas that that's true
and so therefore that's something we are
focusing on through all these different
dimensions PhD education and I GMs funds
almost half of the t32 training slots
for graduate students and undergraduates
that NIH as a whole gives so we really
are the 800-pound training gorilla some
of the things we're really going to be
pushing on over the next five years or
to promote innovation and
experimentation to improve outcomes of
graduate education so I really want to
find ways to empower you the people
doing the training to think about how to
you know change it science has changed
dramatically in the last 15 years and I
think it's maybe time for us to start
exploring other models to improve how
we're training scientists in response to
this changing scientific landscape to do
that though we need to improve our
ability to evaluate how training is
working and to assess outcomes so that's
something we're going to be focusing on
both at NIH and partnership with you and
also on career development there's an
increasing recognition that many people
who get PhDs are going to go into all
kinds of different diverse careers that
utilize their training in important ways
and we want to see if we can improve
their ability to do that and their value
when they get to those diverse careers
outside of the traditional academic
researcher physician-scientist education
is also important nih-wide and to NIGMS
we fund the m stp program the medical
scientists training program that Yale
has one of two fund md PhD students
there was recently an advisory committee
to the director report on physician
scientist education and one of the
things they indicated they would like to
see NIH and the community focus on is
complementary models to the MST program
okay they said we should maintain strong
support for msdp but we should also
think about alternative complementary
models that might be more efficient or
more effective for certain groups of
people overall one of the key issues as
I'm sure you know is retention and
research right there's this huge pool
for a physician scientist to go back
into the clinics especially when it's
difficult to get research funding how
can we promote them to stay in research
in the most efficient and effective way
and finally last but certainly not least
postdoctoral training is something that
I'm very interested in finding ways that
we can improve and use more effectively
seventy percent of life sciences PhDs
and the u.s. right now go on to do
postdocs yet only forty percent go on to
actually run research groups
whether it be an industry or academia is
that the right balance so what is
postdoctoral training for and who should
be doing it if you're spending five
years as a postdoc getting paid forty
five thousand dollars a year and then
you're going to go on into a you know
nan lab head career was that the right
choice or was there a huge opportunity
cost when you could have entered that
Korea directly and paid more money
started your career five years earlier
improving postdoctoral training as a
whole something I'd also like to think
about right right now most places the
postdocs are just working in the lab
they're in and that's pretty much it can
we improve that experience for them can
we add more value to them through some
kind of structured training or mentoring
in various ways and so I think that's a
very important and under thought about
group of researchers in a system i think
we really owe it to the system and to
them to focus more on what's happening
in that space so the last thing I'll say
is just I've told you about a lot of
different things that we're working on
I've totally bought a lot of different
problems in the system I hope I've
convinced you that NIH is taking this
seriously and it's really willing to
make significant changes and try major
new things but the fact is we can make
the biggest changes you can imagine and
theoretically the best but if the rest
of the system is not willing to make
reciprocal changes it will make that
much difference okay so this really is a
shared responsibility and I hope that
you will join us you'll communicate with
us in figuring out how we as a
enterprise can really write this boat
and you know get it sailing the way it
should be sailing again so thank you
very much and I'm sorry it took so much
time I'm happy to say
up there we have two up here okay the
red shirt thank you okay I'll repeat the
question since they're people on the
canvas so the question is how does the
mirror of the r35 mechanism interface
with funding from other Institute's or
private foundations so we are just
limiting the funding to you know that's
your NIGMS grant we're not saying you
can't have others at least not at the
moment right this was a discussion I had
with other IC directors we do though
however have the 750,000 dollar direct
cost triggers what we call it so if an
investigator has 750 thousand dollars or
more in total direct costs from any
source we and our council take a very
close look at the budgets of any grants
we're going to give them and take into
account that additional funding when
making a funding decision and when
deciding how much to give them so that
will factor in and in fact we will
factor this in as we are making funding
decisions as a whole since this is now
your funding from NIGMS if we have one
grant to deal with it's a lot easier
than if there's three others floating
around out there from NIGMS as well
moving forward we'll have to see how it
evolves does that answer your question
yes so that's something again the
question is double funding so someone
gets an NCI grant and their Mira and are
they working on the same thing so that's
again something we're going to have to
monitor very closely at the renewal
stage and at the you know yearly
progress or port stages are these
distinct enough if someone has an NCI
grant is that really about cancer or you
know is there something and there's a
gray area I think we you know
them this is going to be a discussion
moving forward thank you yes so the
question is about salary supports so and
you see it here acutely we have the Dean
of the medical school sitting here you
know at a medical school like I was at
Hopkins or here faculty our frequently
asked to raise 7d or even up to one
hundred percent of their salaries off of
grants that's the system that we've
built up over the years whereas it in
arts and sciences campus it may be the
inverse you may only have to raise
thirty percent your summer salary one
one thing I didn't mention is that one
of the requirements of mirror is that
you put 51% research effort on the grand
51-percent that's research episode
doesn't include clinical time it doesn't
include teaching time it doesn't include
administrative time that helps us with
partly with this is just because it
means that we're not penalizing someone
in arts and sciences campus who is
getting a hard salary by saying you know
you can't take as much effort etc the
you know the overall question though
what are we going to do about this
salary support issue is a harder one
it's when I've been discussing with
various leaders and the community I
discussed it with a double AFC recently
it's something we have to wrestle with
if we want to write that boat and make
it sustainable pulling the plug
immediately I think would be
catastrophic but moving towards some
more sustainable mechanism finding ways
that NIH can support other things
whether it be research resources core
facilities helping with startup packages
in exchange for the institution's taking
long-term commitments the salary
supports I think there are models that
we can work with and I really hope we
can engage more the
you know all of you and with the
academic leaders to find those solutions
because we have 20 there's two more up
here right so with the questions what's
this metric of success for the mirror
pilot and how soon can it be implemented
so I'll take the last first we've
started implementing it already so we're
about you were taking applications now
for that established investigator cohort
we're writing the one for the new
investigator and so hopefully that will
be out in the early summer and then
we'll see how that goes and so that gets
your first part of the question which is
success there are lots of different
metrics we are developing to measure
success so some of them are things like
I showed you like publications comparing
the mirror investigators to the you know
people doing the old r 0 1 system I
admit that's you know publications is
just one thing it's flawed in various
ways but if you saw a big change and one
you know one group relative the other
would tell you something that you wanted
to explore more citations being the same
at cetera my guess is if we give people
more freedom an extra year the average
person gets a little bit more money
we're not going to see a decrease in and
you know those things in a substantial
way to me more the success we have to
look at immediately is can we get more
for the money we have can we support
more investigators with this can we get
a more diverse portfolio of research and
investigators from this as opposed to
the opposite right so failure would be
if for some reason we ended up with a
very small cohort getting you know most
of the money and we'd actually shrunk
our pool investigators and reduce the
diversity of our portfolio so those are
some of the kinds of things we're
looking at if it starts to work we're
going to expand it as fast as we can
yeah so it the question is the mirror
mechanism being considered at other
Institute's yes there's been a lot of
interest from other Institute's I've
spoken at almost 10 councils of other
Institute's now about this usually the
almost all of them the response from the
council has been very positive ni nds
right now is writing something similar
it's actually very much based on ours
it's going to have some tweaks and
differences I think if it does come out
but it's the same idea NCI has an
outstanding investigator award which has
some of similarities but is actually in
some substantial ways different
so how much money is going into it so
established investigators is easy
because they are already there and so
all we're doing at some level is taking
one kind of research grant and changing
it into another okay and so at worst
it'll be a zero sum but we're actually
going to shave as I said some money out
of it and put it back into the system so
its cost at worst neutral the new
investigators what we have to do is
figure out how many we want to fund and
part of what we're doing is looking
historically how many do we fund each
year and then try to decide is that the
right number to start out with or none
that would be the maximum that could
come in because for them any new
investigator could come into that who's
doing work relevant to NIGMS again
though if they get that they're not
going to get an ro1 so it's not it's not
a set aside in the same way that if i
say i'm going to put a set aside to
transcription and give it to them that
would be set aside
yeah yep
absolutely so the questions about
instrumentation and the cost of
instrumentation keeps going up and
keeping the u.s. at the cutting edge
requires continual investment and
support so I didn't have time to talk
about this but another effort that's
going on right now at NIGMS is trying to
optimize our support for both technology
development and access to research
resources okay and understand how to
couple those two things and wind a
couple of those do things so that's
something that will be coming out in the
next year I think two things I will note
about that is one there's a lot of
opportunity for improving efficiency and
creating economies of scale right so if
we can provide say regional resources or
if we can help university set up more
efficient core facilities I think
researchers could get a lot more out of
you know same amount of money
universities could save money we could
probably stretch our dollars more so
that needs to be thought about again in
partnership cry OEM I've had a lot of
discussions with I'll just say we are
absolutely committed and I GMS and the
discussions now going on nih-wide to
finding the best way to provide access
to these amazing new cry OEM tools that
are coming and to promoting their
continued development it's a question of
the most efficient way to do that so
we'll continue these discussions with
the community
oh thank you thank you all thanks a lot
of fun
you